okay four people joining this livestream
we are talking about incremental
language development fourth language we
have a variety of topics today the first
one is about functions that deal with
subsets of things so let's see we are
looking here
okay these are versions of the sequence
things and much patterns are okay that
is a total can of worms I will be amazed
if you can do something reasonable a
subset replace um Tony you were those
here so Tony are you here yes okay so my
first question is you created these in
part to support some sparkle query type
stuff is that correct yes
so it's written a grass-type project
internally okay and and
algorithms reuse part of the sparkle
evaluator okay all right so what I would
imagine should work okay so if I say
what's it gonna do it's gonna give me
one of those okay all right so let's say
I say um by the way how fast is this
stuff so there are many different
situations and for some they are good
what is not yet so for instance for
instance if it can be decided in advance
which patterns will be very selective
and they are evaluated first to keep the
intermediate results small and that is a
huge speed benefit how does it compare
the maxes Seco do we know I haven't
looked for my C++ code doesn't work
reservatol patterns at all I say okay
but in the case where it overlaps do we
know well not really
but it's well let me start with them um
hold on let me just look at something
here
so it's going to break again with
Pacolet stuff
Maxim yes yes
guys that can be fixed by tomorrow that
can be entirely blocked on this and
there is a meeting this evening at 4:30
okay
who's that meeting with David Patrick
and wah wah okay let me see um
I can't do it directly um all right well
offset cases here at insert replaced
right but there is a replacement um but
I don't know how Tony is doing that
replacement so let's take a look at your
documentation pages because the
replacement is a huge can of worms
because of the order in which you do
things and what happens when there are
overlaps and so on make sense
Tony yes but in this case this function
is so far only replacing non-overlapping
things because once you replace it it's
not there anymore to be replaced further
yes Tony but which of the various
possible overlapping things do you
replace first yes okay that that is a
good question so below the over bu there
are some indie agenda notebook get some
other questions for instance how do you
order the things that you want to find
on which further do you return them
right but let me just understand in
subset cases we don't care because we're
going to return all of them including
overlaps right well configurable you can
configure that by an option yeah but
that's not the way we should do it we
should do by true by default I think
it's following the precedent of sequence
cases and string functions yeah
interesting position this is ten cases
and sequence cases was constructed
following string cases let me see what
string cases does purpose so the odd
thing here was and this is something we
inherited from string cases Anniston
position is that those two functions
have different defer yeah I remember
that we thought about that carefully
yeah and I think it's per it's ready to
use in the most frequent case but it's a
bit odd that they have different
defaults string so the sequence
functions do the same
okay so so in this case the default okay
but then there's an ordering which
matters in subset cases right because I
think in string cases so it doesn't
really
tell one the order that it uses right
those are things to be discussed no no
no no no no no no no no I'm talking
about this case here talking about
string cases I think all there is not a
problem here except for the final
ordering of the result
so destruction does not depend on the
order or I don't think that's correct
right because in string cases no no no
in string cases even in string cases I
think it can depend right in other words
if you say okay Jonathan that you guys
come on we can come up with an example
of this this the question is okay if we
have something like this right and we
say string cases of that
let's think if it's the same I mean this
isn't very interesting other than how
many of those it gives okay so it's
giving two of those even though there
are many more if there are overlaps
right right okay let's see how do we get
an ambiguity here we have to have two
things where once you've picked one of
them from the beginning right you can't
get another one
am I making sense right and it matters
that it's a left right scan oh yes I see
watch me but with the option and
assuming a left-to-right scan I've seen
dem big witty disappears
they're also lengths they might have
alternatives and then a a versus a a yes
variable length patterns on interesting
case because they're Metis whether you
are greedy or not into encases is greedy
and doesn't look greedy to me why didn't
it come up with a a a so if you have say
a dot dot it should find a long sequence
of ace no but look at this case yes okay
what that's a bug why isn't that working
see actually it's my lobby bug it just
picks one of them
in other words it doesn't consider every
alternative it yeah I consider the
overlaps but it doesn't consider the
alternatives yeah it is on the order in
which you do the disjunction
okay so this is very screwy behavior I
mean I just don't think we've been aware
of this evaluation order question yet
but we now are aware of it very much so
what happens with overlaps whole no I
didn't know there was an overlap saw
okay let's try overlaps or here
what does overlaps all do oh that's
better
what is it what is it doing
so yeah the documentation says all allow
all overlaps and to allow overlaps
starting at different positions
okay what's the all of that for Tony the
argument or the definition of position
is not really clear how do we bring that
to the subsets in which the position
doesn't matter so for now I think true
and false makes sense but all I'm not
sure yet
okay so the analog for subset cases of
this would be if I have like table one
six or something and then I say one one
one and I do that
okay first okay it's giving two of those
that's the right thing so I have just
hats look at three of those okay great
okay now if I say overlaps to true
should give
so how many of those it should give six
choose two of those
am i right answer that has six choose
two isn't it
come on somebody knows that Pascal's
triangle here um well that's encouraging
okay
that looks very nice Tony
good stuff
okay these are rather weird examples if
I might say so but
well they are specifically constructed
to point out certain design questions
that we might have okay so start asking
your questions
so if you go to the variable links
patterns de Christmas how do you want to
order each single result does the import
determine the order for instance or does
the pattern determine the order by what
determines the order in the general case
of subset cases it's the subset that
occurs first is that right
that comes out first that is the
question that we should ask ourselves so
what the string cases do
I think in string cases the question
does
rice because you are always looking in
order but here we have a choice to make
to be folder input order or the pattern
order I think for most there would be
arguments let me think about that for a
second because Jonathan or over max have
any ideas about that so the question is
if we got so here we are picking subsets
out of this set
and one subset comes from one pattern
I can see I feel like it should do a
left right scan of this of the input set
that's what I think - and then if
there's an ambiguity it should only then
care about the pattern order so if you
scroll a little bit further up yeah
there you can see no oh don't sorry the
other way yes
so we see the whole option one thing now
there we first generate the subsets and
do a slow search through by using order
less pattern sequence yeah so that'll be
one choice and the other choice that
I've implemented is determining the
search by the pattern by the way I have
a simple question in enum is it the case
that
I mean order less pattern sequence is
equivalent to making a function
order lists right yes but not flat right
we have no analog of making we have no
pattern construct that makes a function
flat
correct I think that's correct although
we could do it with double blanks and
things presumably in other words if we
said odorless pattern sequence of
something that contains a triple blank
hmm yeah that's a question okay
you
okay oh it's a women so you're now
determined by the pattern
so you've seen the result the integers
are grouped because they are match
either this one I prefer this one so the
Christian is both results are possible
but they might have different optimal
algorithms in terms of space and time
complexity then we have to do mine
do we want and maybe we should take into
account how can they make compute it no
I would prefer to have the determine by
input one in fact I would much prefer to
have that one that's follows also
subsets itself which is probably
important present here the only
difference to subset this subset start
with the smallest by default and here we
are studying mister biggest because he
want greedy matching I think but apart
from that yeah it follows subsets by the
way why not have a method option in
subset cases that determine some of
these details just for now yep maybe we
shouldn't document it
okay so this is a subset cases where
variable length
I mean you could obviously output these
in any order you want what what is the
point so sort of the reason why that is
important is because how do you define a
non-overlapping case naively or
effectively you could just delete
duplicates by going through the list and
then deleting position lists for which
you have seen a position particular
element already now so that means this
behavior has an impact on the
non-overlapping case and therefore the
runtime in which it can be computed wait
a minute well man I didn't understand
that so if you want to form the
non-overlapping case from dos now you
could go through them one by one and
check which
have you seen already or which ones to
overlap and keep removing them so
depending on the order of the noon of
the overlapping case the non-overlapping
case might have a different order
I am way confused here that Jonathan did
you follow that and he but generally a
lot lon Tully sorry I should prepare
better examples make sense okay try
again Tony are you claiming the answer
you're claiming the runtime depends on
the order in which the answer is
generated or what I'm saying that there
could be such a dependence because for
depending on which order you want you
have completely different algorithms
and who cares I mean you can resort they
are our output of you generated why does
it matter in a non-overlapping case it's
not just a resorting you get completely
different elements I see I see okay
in the non-overlapping case let me let
me just try something actually here so
you're saying yeah I understand so the
question is do you get
I mean the question of the yeah do you
go for the biggest matches first which
does seem like a good idea to me
so you're basically you're changing
which things get excluded in the
non-overlapping case which changes the
elements that get produced that sounds
right
is that correct okay right yeah okay I'm
with you okay
it also gifts the use of some kind of
power because if they can reshuffle the
patterns to get a different result maybe
they want to do that for some reason
you
I'm gonna try
real example here it's kind of
complicated
you
you
see if I can find decent one
you
okay so what we should be doing here
let's take this and we're going to put
blanks in here
so this isn't attempted this is a subset
cases right
subset subset rule replace
and I'm
off with like this
so that should fire
oh yes it cream on you
you
you
okay so now what we want to do
I think that did you mean a sequence of
those pairs on the right-hand side as
opposed to a list of pairs
yeah I'm going to want a cat
each time here so you could say sequence
EDD module I hate sequencer that I don't
like that that's what I want this
flattened auto flattener thing to do yes
but here
what is this doing this is going to
insert these in so if I have a more
complicated case here if I have a so
right now you're replacing two elements
by one because you don't have this
sequence
well this is a good example what has
happened to the diem
what has happened to that thing that is
the auto flattener that sort of auto
flattens into this it's like you but
it's not not really yet okay so if I say
nest list I assume that this is a
courier book creature is it a courier
book Reacher to set replace the subset
replaced curry so only one of those four
functions is currently documented to be
curable because there are issues with
options and confusions of rules that we
both have to discuss but in principle
all should be curable okay so let's see
what this actually does that was
respectably fast and see if we can do it
for 15 steps
stood for 10 steps let's not tempt fate
too much
you
you
you
well that was very fast I wonder whether
it's correct
you
sorry promising weld
Tony yeah so this case is actually
official media because that's the one
that's also good in Sparkle why are we
okay um well I'm impressed let's get
this in the system
I'm seriously impressed actually um
let's do it for 15 steps here
you
that's getting a little slower
well that's grinding that was 6.7
seconds
and to generate a graph with some
thousand nodes and by comparison Maxis
custom code for this type of thing takes
2.3 seconds that's very respectable Tony
well done
I mean well done max also cuz it's I'm
sure Max's code is super efficient but
it's still that's very respectable for
something general-purpose like this
okay I'm highly motivated now let's go
finish this design and get this in the
system so we're hoping this can go in as
experimental for 12.1 right
yes shall we leave the question of the
ordering open because it's experimental
I need to study that more what to make a
recommendation of well I think you
should go ahead and and try and do
whatever you think is going to be
fastest in terms of the implementation
which would probably greedy output with
the longest case first okay
um
okay let's talk about subset replace
okay so these what an earth you actually
do it well I mean this is I just ran
subset replace and it seemed to do the
right I mean how could it have done the
same thing max can you comment on that
is is is what Tony is doing the same
default let's see whether your graphs
are actually well I guess is that simple
case it might be
but you think if there are three
thing on the left hand side little bit
more complicated
you
well I'm not sure but well ideally we
need to run it through my unit test and
see if anything fails that's how we know
it with dozens different do it
you
um okay so max can you provide your unit
tests to Tony
I think so well they would have to be
adopted but yeah okay I mean it's only
yeah right
okay fine let's do it but this is
looking super promising yeah and also if
not a good idea to replace my symbolic
implementation with this completely that
would be cool and well that might be
useful to have it to be as customizable
as possible okay what customization
would you like well like different
ordering and so on I mean if you're
talking about met adoption before let's
put that in I mean whatever Tony can
parametrize please parameterize in the
method option Tony does that make sense
to you yep okay um I'm very impressed
Tony that you managed to get something
that's as close to to Max's custom code
as you have it's really very good well
then um the maybe I better not run too
many more cases because it may not be as
fast for other ones but what are the
names of those method options going to
be
you
maybe something related to ordering or
sorting containing the word ordering or
sorting I'll come up with something okay
all right okay what do we think we're
going to do with subset replace because
clearly there are many possible it's a
very complicated issue of how you do the
ordering for subset replace
I also
really would like to bring back that
that discussion about the mean the only
thing with that Auto flat now that we
have not figured out its name isn't that
correct we know its semantics don't we
and yes we decided to make it we're
discussing at some point about the
second argument specifying the head into
which it auto flattens but I think we we
gave up because it would be too
difficult in health things so it's only
least for a moment yes I think that's
the right thing what was its name going
to be what was the best what was the the
most recent name the last thing we we
discussed was flattened in flattened in
or flattened into doesn't really the
right sorry yeah for a long time we
thought it was flattened so just for
everybody's recollection of what this is
this is something where if you say if
you have a list you say ABC slash dot B
goes to flattened de right well I mean
the motivation to have that list was for
just in case we want some additional
arguments oh we absolutely want the list
here okay that's the useful case you've
got a list and you want it flattened
into something else
lots and lots in aid Max's favorite plug
it should catenate certain point in
racks I then sent this doesn't actually
flatten itself so for example if if this
was the list de like that
the result you would get here is um a de
si yeah that's what i was expect-- right
and and max is making the point that
that isn't really a flattening operation
yeah it sounds like it should be carton
ated instead i see so it's it's flooding
one level
so what that's very obscure
and flatten the bowl doesn't suggest it
will actually do it I mean this is in
the distinguished story of nothing right
it's part of the
but I still think it flattened is more
it is clearer because if I hated a flat
to kind of do too
we talked about um well but it isn't and
it's not it is not doing the action of
unwrapping it is unwrapped a bowl it is
an auto it is a you know it's like a
it's like a I wouldn't say a bomb that
will explode automatically but you know
what I'm saying it's like a it's a thing
that automatically unpacks itself it's
like a delayed flattened what about me
or Justine see the problem is sandra is
making the point it's more like a
sequinsed in I mean inlined
it does not the reload the right word
but something along those lines okay
something like this is kind of
interesting
um enlisted that would be a horrible
horrible pun are we relying on what
heads are we relying on to be the same
here
nothing we're only doing this in lists
we're only planning this for lists right
now um hey could you push the home you
please um
sandra is suggesting in place which is
also not terrible and placed
I think it's a bit obscure to
you
you
yeah this is also a splicing thing the
problem is that we need to make it clear
that it is not that this function is
taking an action this is the thing
that's nice about inlined
is that you don't expect that it is
doing something to DNA itself is merely
that that rapper
you
why is that desirable instead of just
having that evaluate what the heck would
have evaluate to sequence no the whole
point is you don't understand the whole
point is we're trying to avoid the
insane badly defined semantics of
sequence okay of which I would like to
point out if I say a equals sequence of
BC what does it do gives you back
sequence of BC well it's a hack because
this would normally turn that into set
of a BC which would be totally wrong um
right
I like unwrapped I don't because it's
it's it's not that
I mean honestly inlined is the most is
the best sentiment here it's but it
isn't quite I hate the metaphor with
typesetting and you know code macros and
God knows what else right
I would I would avoid it for that reason
alone I mean it's really it's the analog
of inlined because it is would you call
it
let me just see this reminds me of their
discussion about a flood map in which we
were extracting something and putting
something else back and we were
discussing gree insert things by the way
I was also going to mention subset
matting set map in relation to the other
discussion of the subset functions yes
yes yes is it consistent inserted that's
not bad
yeah these things being suggested on our
live stream like unbranded yeah on
bracket is kind of the right sentiment
it just doesn't vary it's sort of a
weird
and syrtis is interesting and not bad
yeah I like it too I mean okay so look
the things we might have we've got
spliced we've got injected
would Embedded have too many other
connotations yes and embedded suggests
it's still there right I mean spliced is
better in terms of not thinking that
it's still there
the problem is spliced is it's a weird
word we did use it for something in
version 1
I like it other than I'm not sure how it
plays with this notion of doing just one
level oh no it's fine with that inserted
is fine with madam that's fine it it's
much better than flattened because if I
say here yeah it's better than flattened
I'm talking about spliced by the way oh
you were too much spliced yeah
yeah I'm not a big fan of injected no I
think it's means too many things show is
this compatible with insert it's not
obviously stupid with respect to insert
I mean it's basically Auto inserting
something I mean if I say okay what
happens if I say this insert um de
opposite unfortunately it does it does
that which is not
um
you
you
but we have to be in Seoul ABC inserted
de to
yes good point okay so that's what you
would actually get there if you wanted
to put those that position - that's what
you would do
looks reasonable to me do you think so I
mean it's a little weird
you
um Brian our livestream assistant
pullout which I wait a second sir
doesn't remove the B though but that's
okay this is a replacement here
what other operations would would we
want to insert a D and an e at position
two has nothing to do with the B yeah
where else would we use this
yeah I mean the problem with unpacked is
that it's just so weird if you see
something in a piece of code absolutely
can I use unpacked yeah I know for other
reasons because it's relates to the
internal packing system
I mean if you saw X goes to inserted a B
in a piece of code it's not obviously
crazy
and you had enlisted before what about
unlisted it sounds very it sounds you
can't find that a be in the phone book
deal
this was delisted no that's silly guys
it's too funny car was advocating
spliced
viced has its merits let's remind
ourselves what splice what the story of
splice is
you
Wow cool we really took it out we can
use this again
okay who knows who remembers what splice
did
come on you guys really nobody remembers
its file template no that's cheating
um well okay if nobody remembers here
does anybody on the live stream remember
um I'm just
okay this is our history moment I think
it was in version one
variks where is the old listing of
building objects b8
okay drumroll
you
you
you
yeah it was actually this is funny I
mean where I'll be using the same
delimiters now that we used in splice in
version 1
um oh the reason it's it's some
yeah all right well listen I you know
maybe it's
me who remembers this it apparently in
this group it is only me who remembers
this good well I think it wasn't a great
use of the name splice originally so
maybe we are good to go with I mean I
think I think that would work
I like it okay very nice okay so the
description then would be
spliced
of it's a list basically I mean it would
always take a list
a list that will automatically be
spliced into another list when it
appears as an element but it's an
expression that automatic will be
spliced into a list when it appears
actually it's something represents
blah-blah-blah in which the east sub i
will automatically be spliced into a
list
you
Cinci
elements so there again represents
represents a sequence of elements Issa
by which will automatically be spliced
into a list
when it appears
Willetta matically be spliced when it
appears inside a list so we want to try
to align this with the wording for
nothing yeah let's look at the wording
for nothing because the the analog
of nothing would be no list or something
okay I got a question why do we need the
list two limiters it's implied to be a
list anyway what list element is inside
the spliced because I think that's gonna
be the most common use case you're gonna
want to insert them you don't want to
have to say spliced at at blah blah blah
this is the case that's interesting by
the time you have those things as
separate arguments you might as well
just put them in the list well okay so
you have X goes you'll replace X with
spliced of ABC I'm not seeing why we
have to have a list around the ABC and
sorry what that the whole point is I
understand that you could imagine that
spliced of ABC on its own would splice
ABC n but I'm telling you the the the
common use case is going to be you've
got a list you wanted Auto spliced into
another list okay then maybe you're so
backpacked cases in which we don't want
to break packing at any point that's
true too and terminally those people are
asking why is it spliced on why is that
wise it's placed in the past tense
because because we use splice years ago
no oh because because it is not an
action that's the whole point it is to
be spliced to be spliced I don't even
know what part of tense what splice in
JavaScript for what it's worth looks
like a generalization of insert what
does that mean does it but it's an
active thing that goes an insert stuff
like irony in both insert and remove
elements from a position fine but that's
a different thing again I mean that this
is what we're trying to do here I mean
okay it's a similar concept but um
ya know it's it's only for lists it's
really not it's not intended for
anything else it's like nothing
represents a knowledgeable list that
will automatically be removed
okay represents an element of a list
that will automatically
are the sequence of elements Issa by
you
that will automatically spice the
sequence of elements into the list
something like that by the way so
sequence also represents something that
is sort of to be spliced but we use a
different part of speech in sequence we
don't use is a disaster sequence should
be removed from the system
think it's correct it was in Version
three it was in version one it just
wasn't documented in version one we
should we should change that that's not
correct we should check but I'm pretty
sure it was in version one and not
documented also we should embrace our
inner sequence and stop saying that it's
a disaster it's a really useful thing
sorry but it is well what do you use it
for other than for spliced well that's
the biggest okay name one other thing
you use it for that isn't semantically
broken I have to think about looking
through my code of which there's plenty
but I'm sure I've used it in I see it
used many times with options so function
comma sequence of a list of options yes
apply sequence to a list for instance
you have your list of lists that you're
gonna use as variables for find minimum
and then you apply sequence to it what's
actually a common use case firm but what
why aren't you just saying they and
minimize whatever it is you know hat
whatever your list is I don't know no I
because I have the the list of objective
function and constraints is the first
argument it's all the other arguments
that that have to be sequenced out and
if I've created them programmatically I
see but then the obvious thing to do
would be to use spliced and to put your
original thing in there you're you know
objective and constraints or whatever in
there and then and then your options
here and then that will just turn into a
list of of absconds opts right that
might be the new way to go about this
see I'm telling you we can get rid of
sequence yeah although wait a sec that
would be the right way way to go about
this you're not gonna get rid of
sequence that easily by the
way except that spliced is only going to
be slicing in lists or is it only or is
the only restriction the list our
argument to spiced what other words n
minimize of a comma splice whatever
comma C is that spliced going your head
is and minimize now is the splice going
to know it would only work inside the
list okay okay
daddy was another pointing out the two
on when you uh nikon eyes sequence shows
up which is true i mean it does it
actually show up or does it just
automatically splice in it does
oh look at this disgusting fact look
look at the description there so splice
represents a bunch of whatever's that
are going to be sequenced in very funny
um well it is amusing that we use that
son terminology in sequence the question
on the live stream being asked is should
it work for associations as well mute
please actually do i wanted to say
something though liz also in a meeting
but as with associations how we're going
to handle the key business or mining
this understanding yeah well so the
question then is if you were to splice
into an association here i don't know
how that would look
i don't know how that will look what
what's that yes doesn't working right
that sounds like very much like Odysseus
and the Cyclops but nothing doesn't work
in associations presumably if this was
going to work in an association we would
want to be spliced of another
Association not a list that's a good
point but I don't even see how this can
work in an association because I think
by the time it's seen the splice there
it's already too late the thing is
already totally confused and and and
clearly if we had a key there that key
can't be repeated so that's not going to
work either
um
you
well I like this and I think that this
this really
does strongly suggest that it's name is
was preordained so to speak can we can
we go ahead and try and implement this
thing should be quite easy yes I don't
know I thought we had an implementation
of it I think we do but but it should be
it should follow the same principles of
nothing but was ready please write who
did nothing okay so okay yeah no I I
mean I know it sounded funny but I was
serious because I had no recollection of
how this was done
so let's say if constant and notice
would be able to do this one - all right
let's let's return that this will be
really nice to have by the way since
we're talking about these kinds of
things I am considering this function
called collection um
which would be
and an inert annele
repeats are allowed set like thing
how do people feel about this thing in
other words it's a it is simply you know
it really is a function that does
practically nothing all it has is a
bunch of is the attributes order less
and I guess it might have the attribute
flat as well is going in there in the
theory in the direction of multi-sets
yes we could think of it that way I'm
not sure you flood yeah I'm not sure
either anyway for a different meeting
oh my gosh there's oh that's
still call points out this this is
depressing and outrageous but the claim
is made you can't be serious
how can that still be there Oh sigh
could somebody let documentation folk
know about this that function has been
deprecated only five years um
okay all right let's return to Tony's
stuff any further questions from Tony
plus with Tony's thing here many I mean
I guess with subset replace there are
complicated questions evaluation order
which we are simply not addressing at
this time
okay I mean the but but do we have any
thought about how we would parameterize
them if we were to parameterize them
in what kind of example well the case
that I'm most familiar yeah the other
thing I'm sorry I want to talk about
subset map for a second and whether
there's some horrible problem there so
subset map
it is quite different and I don't see a
way of implementing a mapping function
in Tony's framework yeah I don't think I
do either
um subset yeah I think subset map does a
fine thing and you know the issue is
subset map is saying what subset where
as Tony's stuff is all finding the
subset for itself right so and we would
want some generator of subsets that we
can iterate over right
um chatter sub
that's a different thing right that that
that's actually a thing Edie was working
on peg was working on this index subset
mechanism I don't want anybody in this
meeting knows about that that's a
general find you and just I do what
subsets itself takes a third argument
with an index really does that know that
is no efficient I don't know a good
question you know I also don't know that
maybe all in the second argument
I want to get the there you want to get
the second element is how many elements
correct
yeah and literally with the least least
four found when attempting to take the
sequence what well I mean clearly if I
do that wow that was pretty simple II
fast huh so I then you know what it's
doing it's just taking the binary number
right it's just taking to get I think so
if I take
you
you
you
what is the second are the second
argument is how many elements in the
subset which I said four here okay and
this is giving the 10,000th so for
example the first subset with four
elements i would hope would be something
like one two three four so i wonder if
the last element is findable as well
that should be yeah that looks very
reasonable and everything in between
i mean there should be two to the
hundred such subsets right
oh no not not there's my sorry 100
choose four subsets here right okay so
it's still a respectable number of
subsets um okay so what was the okay so
I'm sorry
coming back to subset replace again
there is a question which we have evaded
in replace all which is the replacement
order it replace all has a particular
way
that tum
a particular order in which it does
Replacements right how does the replace
all
how does replace relate to
subset replace I mean clearly replace in
a flattened order in a in a flattened or
dysfunction should be equivalent to
subsets replace should it not I don't
think so because if you use replace you
can replace one edge at a time while a
subset replace you replace a set of
edges so that's a difference no you're
losing a flat function you can perfectly
well replace a set of things right in a
flat function I can perfectly well say
in an order less flat and all this
function or actually just all of us
you're right I could replace two at a
time that's why the analogy to order
less this order less pattern sequence
there
so the whole idea of this approach
to have something even more efficient
than other less pattern sequence or much
more fish right but I'm asking the
question how do you parameterize which
replacements you actually do
right because in general you could do a
greedy type thing where you try and
stuff in let's say you've got a bunch of
pairwise replacements to do right
there's many different possible you know
you've got ABCD and you can pair
anything with anything but you're going
to use them up once you've paired them
so you might do a B and then you do C D
or you might do a CBD how do you decide
which one to do
did you understand my question yeah I
see so so in other words let's let's
take that example as a specific okay so
let's say we do this and we say well we
can just do subset cases here I think
and then all we're doing is we're saying
blank blank okay so now we say that's
great but now we say overlaps to true
you
and the claimers that overlaps to true
will get us everything all drew
something intermediate well all it's not
clear that it all makes sense in the
subset functions
you
right but so in cases there's not an
issue it's in replace that there's an
issue because replace it's got to decide
which of these it's gonna do well even
in cases they might been issuing if you
use the rules form that's correct
no that's not correct that's not correct
because I can do whatever I want here I
can say you know X Y goes to you know f
of X Y and it's gonna give all of them
it's just gonna take the results and
yeah it could be that the first argument
where you have X underscore you have
another list where you say
a double underscore comma B double
underscore and then you get different
matches or defect the different
possibilities it doesn't matter whether
there's a thing on the right-hand side
or not right well you only see the
difference if you rap let's say each a
the a and the B in a list on the right
hand side so you're saying here I say
let's say you double blank V double
blank is that correct the U and V both
enlist because you want that to be one
element in the first set
now so you wouldn't have ABCD there but
lists of lists I think this is already a
weird case right because we got this
case UV right and then that case
yes this case already well why doesn't
this case already have the have the
issue
so this one is handled by true and false
this case okay so what's the case that
isn't if you have a list of lists and
they're okay so let's say table let's
say I I squared I goes up to five for
example and those lists have different
links okay all right so yeah it's a very
constructive no no no no no no no no
it's not that constructed let's let's
let's let's go through the case please
yeah you have for instance instead of
one one you have one one one no okay
in our work and then group dos U and V
into a list
why does not have anything to do with
this it's not gonna match yes because
now you're matching pairs no oh gosh
yeah oh so now there are two ways of
binding this first triple dare hold on
hold on let me look at this hold on
so you're saying I'm pairing up a single
element with two elements here this is
similar to our multiple hyper graph
isomorphism case I think if Max and
Jonathan know what I'm talking about
there so total to say it in a different
way in this case each element of the
list can be matched in different ways so
maybe that is outside the scope of
subset cases or maybe each element of
the list what are you saying here so if
instead of one one one you had one two
three to better
see the difference and then you also
wrapped U and V in order less pattern
sequence then you would have different
ways of matching that one two three
element you're saying here I put that in
all those pattern sequence yes but you
still need to list around the order left
pattern sequence because it's it seems
to be outside of the scope because it's
on the level which is not an ordered
yeah what do you mean what do you mean
by that well the subset case a certain
subset cases means that the first level
of it is unordered but this has to do
with second level
I am really quite confused by this okay
if you guys convince yourself that's not
in this year but but can it can we come
back please two subsets replace because
subset replace definitely has this issue
right in this case here if I were doing
subset replace it's got to make a
decision about what to do
oh the issue is a place not a subset
replace why didn't it work
um overlaps all it's not really
symphonic okay okay I was typing loudly
did you um okay so subset replace does
not support an overlaps option so what
you're saying is that correct correct
because once it's replaced it's made a
commitment yes it's eating up
once that can be matched
okay so this is all as overlocker so
true is going to be multi-resistant yes
which we have no way to represent
currently
right but you're saying it's an issue
with replace because you're saying the
same thing could I could do the same
thing with replace here I could just say
X blank blank
y blank blank goes to f of XY
effortlessly sex destroyed and who knows
what this is going to do
to do that it's kind of dunno because we
can specify longest shortest and so on
on the partner right so that does that
which is fine
I mean clearly if that was a whole trees
worth I don't think longest is good
enough to distinguish those that makes
sense
so you couldn't take a second argument
of longest to specify priorities what
does that mean so if you have multiple
longest then are you telling me that
means that the thing you just made up or
is that no it's assert details aligned
so that would be
to control that if you want to implement
it in the subsidy cases of course you
want where would we put that in subset
cases the subset repels it wherever you
specify a variable-length pattern yeah
you can
these aren't variable like this is a
different issue here right this is how
it eats the original list okay so so max
are you claiming are you guys all
claiming that longest is sufficient to
parameterize the behavior of replace
I'm not sure that's correct I'm not sure
it's correct when the thing is order
list for example
I think the case that's bad here if if
that original replacement were order
less let's I mean we don't have a let me
just use plus as a symbolic order less
function here although that that has a
bunch of other things like one identity
properties if I do that and then I say
this
you
you
it's going to do that so if the question
get all of the possible combinations or
how to pick one how to specify which one
should be picked yeah why not have a
selection function option which just
takes cases or subset cases and then
picks one
that's very reminiscent of something
else you and I both know about well it's
why I thought about it but it seems to
work right so in that case the selection
function is simply taking a list of
possible things to do and making a
decision which one to do so it could
take the first of those it could sort
them in some order right right it's just
slow well depends because we could have
something which says you know what would
it be cool it will be good something
like pattern selection function and it
could certainly have some string values
right
like gradient
the question is is that what is the
ultimate way to parameterize this I mean
it's one thing so we can say here all
the matches but okay so for example
greedy is one parameterization this is
reminiscent of you know in recursive
function evaluation there's there's all
this stuff about leftmost innermost you
know rightmost outermost all these kinds
of things I think I think it's
reminiscent I think it's the same
question
in other words
if you are you know if you've got a
choice of function evaluations let's say
you're doing a Fibonacci computation and
you say if I've got F of 10 goes to F of
9 plus F of 8 do I then evaluate F of
and then I've got F of 9 goes to F of a
plus F of 7 etc do I go and run down the
left most part of the tree evaluating
drilling down to evaluate F of 7
blah-blah-blah-blah-blah down to F of 1
or do I you know take bigger pieces of
the tree and do things with them first
so what what kind of functionality do we
gain by this pattern selection function
compared to pattern test or condition
you
I think there are things that happen
because of the globality of it you can't
do with a pattern test yeah I mean a
pattern test is just saying hello I'm
I'm a pattern am I going to match
right so in other words in today's here
only merit we nominate all orders then
just comparison wouldn't be enough
in other words what you're giving there
is a a ranking function you're not
giving your rank you know you're just
saying yes or no Tony and what would be
the arguments the whole expression or
the surroundings or
why ask my some device suddenly came to
life here and started talking to me that
is very bizarre okay no matter um
they okay sorry what were you just
saying so what would be their argument
steps at a function gets it gets the
candidate
results so
it gets focused
so matches what's that okay okay so it
gets all the results so therefore it is
strictly more powerful than pattern test
yes I see okay I think that I mean that
is the ultimate the question here is
what are the primitives if you work on
it to build a pattern selection function
what are the useful primitives for
building a pattern selection function
because you're gonna be given a boatload
of potential matches here let's take
this example here right you're going to
be given the potential matches there
well we can actually list them right the
potential matches are precisely the
subset cases matches with overlaps to
true
you're going to be given all of those
and then there is a subset of those that
in other words there's a yeah yeah this
is interesting there's a dependency tree
here right because if you pick one there
are others you can't have so how do you
represent that
you go what I'm saying yes
you
Jonathan do you have any thoughts about
this not immediately but that's an
interesting point which I hadn't really
internalized that there's a there is a
hierarchy of these things right
um so in fact probably the most general
way is you don't want to just return one
you want to give some priority listing
that no that gives your ranking function
well I say see what you're saying
you're but it can't be a local ranking
function it's got to be something which
applies over the whole thing yeah right
because in general right and your point
is yes it's not good enough to take one
you you are getting a subset of the
subset cases that will be used for the
replacements right
um Tony what is the sparkle
interpretation of what we're talking
about right now so in some sense it can
be considered a special case because in
sparkle we usually have lists of three
element lists so this is a
generalization
the only difference or only is that set
versus list semantics but it's a detail
no no but but wait a second well I'm
asking is what is the interpretation of
this issue of the multiple forms of
subsets replace what is the
interpretation in terms of sparkle
queries of that so replace the analog in
Sparkle is the sparkle update language
which is very carefully designed that
you first pick your matches and then you
pick which one do you remove which one
do you insert so it's not there general
it's carefully designed to be useful in
the sparkle case okay but what I'm
asking is this particular thing can we
think of this as you know this is
replacing an attribute of an entity of
or whatever and there are multiple ways
to do it or is there some interpretation
I just I'm not sure what the
interpretation is in the world of
sparkly type things
if there is one
because the thing
yeah so the problem
goes away in a very specific way but I
can't explain it easily okay fair enough
on ok for instance if you select all
pairs of cities I want to do something
won't it be the same problem
well so maybe Alec I try to explain it
yeah yeah yeah you're right you're right
you're right it's easy max max is right
look the fact is if it's like
you're replacing pairs of cities by I
don't know what what the example would
be lets say you're replacing pairs of
movies by whichever movie from the pair
is the favorite one or something right
and the question is which pairs do you
replace first if you've got a whole
bunch of things and you know all in all
cases you're replacing pairs by I don't
know the the favorite movie or whatever
you're going to get different answers
and in fact the question of whether you
get different answers or not is a
confluence question isn't it
so in sparkly you first compute so you
first you have a pattern and there you
compute certain bindings and this stem
you determine which edges to delete and
then which which ones to insert so
there's no real replace operation it's
more first delete some then insert but
the thing I describe it so question for
Jonathan Mac's primarily how does this
relate to confluence if this if this
thing is a confluent rewriting system I
claim it isn't gonna make a difference
what you do am i right is that nonsense
which you do first
no I I think I think you're correct or
at least as long as we're limited to the
cases where this is guaranteed to
terminate it won't matter
you couldn't principle have
non-normalized zing replacement rules
yes but what you're saying is the analog
you're talking about subset replace all
right right so in a single step it might
not be the same actually right and I'm
sorry you're doing a subset replace
repeated yes yeah so so what you're
talking about I think would be strong
confluence where it doesn't you know
things reconverge in one step
compliments is just saying that
eventually they'll be the same
right one step say it's not just a
recommendation they don't at all
yeah yeah that's a good point they
should reconverge in two steps
okay so not only laughing this storm
conference what what is the
generalization of the notion of
overlapping for this okay so the other
question then Tony is subset replace
repeated that's what we're basically
talking about here
which I think in many cases many of the
interesting cases won't terminate which
isn't very useful
repeated that would be different from
nest for fixed point
well is replace repeated equivalent to a
fixed point of replace all I think it is
I think in a very special sense no I
think there was some discussion a year
ago but I don't remember good details ok
ok the thing that's bugging me and we
have to wrap this now but but the thing
that's bugging me and I'm kind of
interested in for a different reason
is this question of what what the kind
of tree of possible what you can pick in
that subset cases example is
other words
because I could make this I mean it's a
graph I think of what I can pick when
right from that list once I've picked F
of a B I
excluded everything except fo BC in this
case ever sorry F of C D in this case
once I picked F of AC similarly I've
determined something but let me make the
more complicated case if I do this
oops I didn't prompting there um if I do
this then having picked F of a B I have
multiple choices left
right
yes I think this is an argument maybe of
having the pattern selection function
not take the list of cases but actually
request it on demand
you
you mean once something has been done
then it recomputes so the pattern
selection function would take the
current state of the set and the and the
pattern it would get it would call
subset cases and then it would take one
right but my question is what are the
primitives that are useful in pattern
selection function
I mean we know a particular greedy case
where it's going to try what it isn't
really greedy I mean max thing you
implemented in cetra place is
that tries to cover as much of it as
possible is that correct this innocently
place is that it keeps the least of all
marches all the time therefore I can
solve them in any way I like
currently it sorts them by age
essentially but it doesn't try to pass
them as as many as it was possible what
does it do it it scans in order having
but wanting things which have not been
which are least recently updated is that
correct yes so it tries to do it goes
through in order and the least recently
updated is the one that it will choose
to update if it can
is that right or does it go through in
the order of at least recently updated
well it's it's so the most recent of the
one it has chosen true there's all this
possible
that's all of us the most recent of the
ones it chooses should be as old as
possible yes
how does it know
and it chooses the thing the next thing
that will work
yeah yeah and it's also mattress when
they appear and I put them in a set in
size I mean C++ said okay this requires
more thought and we ran out of time just
one comment is this perhaps as I've said
to replace lists effectively yes yeah
the list would be really big in their
normal case right subset replace list is
the thing that will generate everything
which we don't want
instead we want some kind of selection
function which picks out particular sub
elements in the list
listen cuz replace list is doing
everything
do we have a string replace list I can't
remember I know I've written such a
thing
he's asking so I think we do yes yes we
do okay well so we're using it yes the
UM all right
for people who are curious by the way
the the they're all this subset
replacement stuff is highly relevant for
the physics project that will finally
have good things to say about in a month
or so um anyway all right well sorry we
didn't get as far on this list as some
as I'd hoped but I'm still Tony you made
my day these dysfunctions are working
much better than I thought they would so
good stuff okay great so what would be
the timeframe till when should they be
in system now okay right now that I
looked at the documentation of subset
cases it looked just fine let me just
look at subset I think it might be worth
some comments about um
yeah in certainly in the properties and
relations and/or the possible issues you
should talk a bit about this replacement
order thing yes okay
yeah I suspect that this does only the
first n replacements is going to be kind
of silly and that that third argument
should be used in a more sophisticated
way but I don't think this will be a bad
thing to have
great let's do it and we can we'll work
at a different time on letting them into
other pages okay okay good stuff thanks
a lot guys and thanks to folks on the
livestream for a bunch of good
suggestions um and yeah okay see you
later